I feel that I work for every employee
and I really show up that way attention
is the number one asset do you view your
companies uh from a sports standpoint
almost do you see yourself as a coach
first of all I think that almost every
CEO and boss has it wrong it was funny
when you even said the word what
happened in my stomach it didn't feel
good because I think the world has
defined boss as person that tells you
what to do person that's keeping you
accountable so yes I think more of
myself as a coach as a parent as a
guidance counselor as an older brother
feels very appropriate I am the oldest
in my family again it was an immigrant
family so my mom I mean from the time I
was six I remember my mom saying like
you have to take care of your sister you
know like you're out there at 8 years
old you're eight you're you're a child
you're a baby eight and you know I'm
keeping an eye on her and I got to fight
if somebody makes fun of her like real
[__] and so yes I I I I do view it that
way